hello everybody
and welcome to full stack with either
kotlin or dart
on google cloud my name is grant
timmerman
and i'm joined today by james ward and
tony pujols
so let's talk about serverless on google
cloud so
what is serverless well first serverless
is an operational model
where you have no infrastructure
management you have managed security
and you pay per use second it's a
programming model is service space
it's where you can build event driven
services
and it uses open source
but customers often ask us the following
questions
how can we use existing binaries we
can't be locked in
can we support this language or
how do i choose between containers and
serverless
so that's where cloud round comes in
cloud run allows you to develop and
deploy
highly scalable containerized
applications
on a fully managed serverless platform
with cloud run you run containers so
containers allow you to run
any language any library any binary
where you can go and pick from an
ecosystem of base
images one of the great parts about
serverless
and cloud run is that you pay per use
so that means depending on your cpu
memory and request usage your bill
to 100 milliseconds so you can go and
make your services
public with the allow unauthenticated
flag
this is great for websites for example
but let's say
you don't want public you want to make a
private service
so private is the default with cloud run
so it's great for microservices and for
handling events and asynchronous tasks
next up event turk
eventark is a google cloud product that
allows you to deliver
asynchronous events to your applications
so let's back up why events well we're
in a world
moving towards real-time communication
so that means
your applications are expecting rapid
delivery and consumption
of different services many to many
messages
where you might get a message from a
different service
and maybe a couple and then you're also
expecting on-demand scalability and cost
so let's say in real life like you get a
new photo is that added to your cloud
storage bucket
maybe you get a new message from pub sub
or a new audit log
well with eventark you can take all
these sources
and you can create a trigger this is the
main
resource in event arc this allows you to
specify
uh which service will receive that event
and so whenever one of those events is
fired
it'll create a event that's sent to your
cloud run service
so what is a cloud event well it uses
the hb
protocol so within your hp
request is the cloud event which has
metadata
some context these are standard
attributes like the id
the time is sent and then it has your
actual application data uh with event
arc we use
binary encoded cloud events so this
means
you'll get an hp post request to your
slash route uh you'll get some standard
uh hdb headers that are for cloud events
with the ce-flag
and then you'll get your normal payload
in this case for a pub sub event we also
have a set of libraries that allows you
to write your applications as a function
these are available in a large set of
languages
including kotlin and dart and can listen
to hp requests and cloud events so we
know that full stack developers
like to use the same language with the
front end and back end
one of the awesome things that's
available with kotlin and dart
that we can use the same language across
both the front and back end
so now james and tony can go and show
you the magic
hi i'm james ward so i want to show you
kotlin multi-platform
running on google cloud and a bunch of
clients
so first i'll show you the demo i'm in a
web application here that's running on
google cloud using a google cloud load
balancer
and cloud run and cloud sql and this is
just a basic
data driven application so i can come in
here
and add a bar to my database
so that's a web application now we also
have
a desktop application that works the
same way with a different ui
i can of course add bars in there and
then i also have an android application
which works the same way and i can come
in and add bars on the android
application
but then for yet another client let's
hop into my ide
and i have a cli application so i can
run that
this will compile i could of course turn
this into actually a native application
and distribute it to mac
linux and windows uh but here i'm just
running it from my ide
just to see how that works and then we
can of course come in
and add a new bar and see the bars that
were there
so all those different clients were
connecting up to my server running on
cloud run
and of course they're all built with
kotlin so let's walk through the code
i have a shared common module in this
data kt file
and this allows me to share code across
all the different
clients and servers that are part of
this application
in this case all that this common module
has is a data class
which is a bar so this holds my data
that i store into the database
it has a primary key that's a long and
it has a name that's a string
so that's the common module now let's
dive into the server
my server is built with spring boot and
it uses spring native to compile this
down into
a native application that runs on cloud
run of course we can
we containerize that application into a
docker container
and it starts up in milliseconds so this
connects up to my database using a
reactive crud repository and then my i
have my rest mappings i have a git
mapping for
api bars and that just does a query to
the database to get my list of bars
you'll see that it's a suspend fund so
that's a non-blocking
reactive request and then i have my post
mapping which allows me to add new bars
to my database that just takes a
json post and parses the json and then
allows me to save that bar
so that's shared from that comma module
i save that into the database
and then do an http response so that's
all there is for my spring boot server
let's take a look at the web application
so again my web application is written
in kotlin
and i get to take advantage of all the
nice features of kotlin
it's all type safe but i can do dom
manipulation in
the browser and do like the window fetch
api to go fetch my bars
of course that comes back as an array of
bar so again we're using that code
between
the this compiles down into javascript
so i get to reuse that
and reuse the kotlin code write my code
in kotlin
and there's the rest of my ui that's
that's manipulating the ui
creating the form adding the event
handlers that sort of thing
so that's my web application to look at
the android and desktop applications i
actually have a shared module for the ui
because there's something called jetpack
compose that allows me to share code
between the desktop application
and the android application in this case
i have a bars which takes a url to
connect to i'm using a ktor client
library
to make my http requests and then i have
my ui written in jetpack compose
so fetching the list of bar again you'll
see the code reused between those
and then i have my ui that's rendering
the list of bars
and has the form with the form handler
and that sort of thing to add a bar
then the kotlin code all it has to do is
set the content
to that reusable compose piece there and
then similarly
my desktop application creates a window
and then reuses that bar
ui from that common module so
that's all of the code that it took to
build this application with the server
the web application the android
application the desktop application
and then the cli which is over here is
very similar to what you saw with the
spring boot client because i'm actually
using spring boot
to create the command line client as
well and then with spring native i can
compile this down into a native
executable
if i wanted to distribute that to the
different platforms that's all the code
that there is for that application
you can find that all up on my github
github.com jamesward and then
kotlin-bars
and instructions for how to deploy that
up on google cloud are all in that
repository
so check that out that's kotlin and
we're using that across many different
platforms
so hopefully that was useful for you now
over to tony
hey everybody i'm i'm tony priggles i'm
an engineer at google
and today we're going to talk about full
stack dart
on google cloud i'm a firm believer that
you should use whatever
language is most appropriate for you to
solve the problems you need to solve
on the back end so if you're for example
writing a service that has to do a lot
of numerical calculations
then maybe you should be using python or
r
all that being considered for most
development teams you're going to find
that there's a lot of synergy
a lot of momentum that you get when you
use the same language on the front end
and on the back end
and what we're finding is that flutter
has become this really popular
ui framework uh and developers are using
it to build all of these really cool
cross-platform applications and by
cross-platform i mean it runs on
mobile it runs on web and it runs on
desktop on windows on mac and linux
and the language for programming flutter
is dart
i myself am new to flutter and i am uh
really impressed with how cool it is for
developing applications
and i built a little demo app over the
uh over the weekend and what i'm gonna
demonstrate here is this
little front-end app is gonna talk to
our back-end app written in dart
a lot of people don't realize that you
can actually use dart on the back end
and it works very well
dart is very performant we compile it to
a native uh
native binary application and it runs
on on the cloud run platform in a
container and starts up fast
executes fast so the first thing i want
to do is i'm going to introduce this
demo
it's here on github you can go to
subfusion
dart flutter full stack demo
and i'm going to do a quick walkthrough
first thing we'll do is we'll go into
the clone of the repo
on my system i've cloned it here under
projects and i've opened up two
uh terminal panes to show the back end
and the front end
the back end is uh easy to start
you can look in the docks and see all
the commands that you would need to get
going it's just going to be a build
and then a run but i've simplified that
even further so if you have make on your
system just run make run
and that's going to start up our dart
server
on localhost
and now i'm going to go ahead and i'm
going to run our front end
i'm on a mac and i've so i'm going to
target mac os
and this is going to go ahead and
launch the application on mac os
here we go here's the app it's up and
running i'll enter my name
hit enter and there you go we can see
that i got a response here
bonjour tony it's in french and the
server went ahead and logged that there
was a greeting response
and success and http 200.
so here's what's cool this is easy this
is running locally but let's go ahead
and run this up on cloud run let's go
ahead and submit our code
i'll use gcloud this is a beta command
because it's going to be
um it's a new command that does
everything in one
in one operation it's really cool it's
going to go ahead and send
the contents of this directory to the
back end cloud build is
going to build it and then deploy it on
the cloud run so gcloud beta
run deploy
the back the service is called greeting
and the source
is going to be this directory and we
want to allow
unauthenticated
for public access
and now we can run our app
and this time i need to tell it that i'm
going to run it in the prod environment
so i have to do this dart defined for
the environment
env variable that we have defined in the
app
and it will load prod dot json this time
and when it starts
we'll be able to ping our back end and
this time won't be this back
end and we'll see nothing here this is
going to be our cloud run back end
if you notice there's a little bit of a
delay first time that's because the
service actually spun up it was a scale
down to zero this is serverless
um you can set them in instance to uh
one but in this case it was zero
and so there was a split second while it
started and now if i hit it again
it'll be my it'll be much faster
there you go hello world so how do we
know
well let's take a look at our logs
here's the app on the back end
on cloud run and i am going to
check out the latest logs
and here you go we can see the uh uh
the greeting for tony and then the next
greeting for
world in our cloud run logs so let me
show you what's here in the repo
first of all there's the back end and we
scaffold
this using dart f dart fn the dart fn
tool that's part of the functions
framework for dart
it's a very simple app
it's going to take a greeting request it
responds with a greeting response
it defaults to world if you don't supply
a name there's
the response this is what we logged and
that's what i just showed you a second
ago in cloud run
that's it the only other thing to know
about this uh demo
is the greeting request and grading
response types
they're defined here in api types.dart
they're json serializables so when we
build the app
the parts app also gets built for
handling the serialization
we defined it using these uh annotations
here and
that's it now
on the front end we have a service here
for invoking this api it also is going
to
access serializers for um the green
request
and green response so when we sent our
request we
encoded the name that was provided in
the form
and then we wait for the response we we
post
this request we make sure that we set
application json we get a response
and then we're going to display it
there's a model
for the class in here that handles
sending that greeting and then notifying
listeners
and what we're seeing is
here inside of the greeting widget this
is where the
name is provided and this is where
information gets applied in the snack
bar that shows a response that came back
that's it and if you want anything
simpler than this then
just take a look at the command line
version it's dead simple
okay so now that we've seen that working
let's go back here um
again this demo app is located here at a
subfusion dart flutter full stack demo
all the instructions are here it's also
a part of
one of the official examples in the
functions framework for dart
and the functions framework for dart is
where that dart fn tool came
came from and you can come here you can
see
other examples and you can check out
docs for
how to get your back end up and running
obviously you know it takes a team to
get
stuff done and i want to give thanks to
some of my colleagues as well as members
of the community so kevin moore
product manager at google for the dart
team and
grant timmerman uh the architect for the
functions framework
jeff hewlett and then um
these people in the community jason rye
jermaine oppong
and simon lightfoot who all contributed
in some way to the demo
thank you everybody and good luck good
luck folks with checking out
uh the dart functions framework building
your full stack applications run on
google cloud
and if you are curious about any of the
parts that i skipped here
because due to time go ahead and take a
look at this raw unfiltered unedited
video that is exactly
13 minutes long that shows you start to
finish cloning the repo
creating your project all the things all
the
all the little extra details you'll miss
in this very short five-minute
version of the video thanks folks have a
great day bye
you